i was just going to say
a huge congratulations i mean we have to
talk about music there's so much to talk
about okay yeti you mentioned it
congratulations how proud are you of
this moment
it's a big moment for me like i've been
planning for
this moment right here for like five
years now um
five years is when i had the first talks
to start
the yeti shapewear company and then
we've been working and developing it for
three years um and here we are baby it's
launched it's launch season not only
that watch out for the big girls is out
and i've been working that's been
something i've been trying to do since
2014.
you know what i mean and now it's
finally here and now the album in my new
song about damn time it's about damn
time because i've been working on this
album for three years three and a half
years now so all of this i've just been
like
i can't wait till it's out and now it's
out and i'm just like
whoa
yeah it feels like listen you've been
percolating on a lot of
really incredible
big things for a very long time and to
have them all was it a plan to have
everything kind of come together at once
absolutely it was the master plan girl
wink week
[Laughter]
right that's life right yep that's life
that is the universe the universe has a
way of working itself out and i feel
like with me
um
there are no accidents you know what i
mean like everything everything happens
on its time on the right time
yeah there's a line in this song that
says i'm way too fine to be this
stressed out so how do you decompress
when life does sometimes get heavy or it
gets stressful or just you feel weighed
down by that
well
i listened to about damn time by lizzo
my favorite artist
and i crack open a brewski um i love you
i love it i feel like this song is that
though actually um
because i i wanted to write a song that
when i'm on stage and i'm performing i
feel better
immediately in that moment and i did
that was good as hell
i wasn't trying to do it was good as
hell though you know good as hell was
like
came out of me like you know ariel and
little mermaid but
every time i'm on stage it doesn't
matter what i went through that day when
i sing good as hell i get emotional i i
get happy and i'm like i need a song
like that again so when i'm dealing with
all of the anxieties of the world yes
and i think we can all agree there's a
lot of anxiety in the world i can sing
this song and kind of be present for a
moment and and and and recharge myself
to take on the world
that's it well we're all really in
charge of our own thoughts when you have
a song like this it directs you in that
direction of where to go if you're
having a bad day for sure
um
this is a real feeling yourself song and
very empowered i visualize myself like
roller skating or driving down the
highway with the top down like that's
where it kind of took me those are the
thoughts i was getting um where do you
see people listening to the song or
enjoying this song
i see people um sorry there's a
helicopter
right on top of my house in a helicopter
they're in a helicopter enjoying the
song they're listening to about damn
time right now
um
i see people listening to it any and
everywhere i was hiking um
up running canyon once and
somebody walked by me and said i'm
listening to rumors right now oh i love
that
they're like rumors is getting me up
this hill
yeah see
it was really cool because i'm like yeah
you can use this music anywhere you can
use my music for any occasion um any
time
um and that's hopefully but hopefully i
see it in the club and that we get back
to going to clubs in a healthy safe way
again wouldn't that be amazing i love
that well listen in the song you do talk
about going out having a really great
night what does a great night look like
for you
um
it's so funny
some of the most fun
me and my friends have is like
at home
i know i know i know
we'll have like a full karaoke night
because i got these karaoke mics now
it's
that's epic
we've been singing and drinking like
sometimes it's so much more fun than
even going out we go out we look cute we
get the photo and then we come home and
we turn up it's drinking it's tequila
champagne shakila is dancing
we have one night where we just danced
non-stop in my kitchen and like i was
sweating through my clothes and we are
all just dancing like peanuts characters
like charlie brown in them in our own
little vibe like
it's so fun i have so many djs
in my friend group like my best friend
sophia eris is literally a dj but like
also my assistant is a great dj and like
she just be playing the best music so um
i'm really blessed to have people great
people around me and we make a party
literally anywhere we go we can make a
party in that room right there with the
little i love the flowers i believe that
well everybody knows and every woman
knows it's the getting ready before we
go out that's the party before you go
like you have the most fun getting ready
with your friends and just having
pre-drinks and hanging out right oh wow
i forgot that in canada y'all go ooh you
don't go out you go eat
okay maybe we do maybe we do maybe
um you've been working as you mentioned
on this album for like three years uh
this is the second single what vibe is
the entire album like what is the vibe
okay here's the thing i changed the
album last minute and i took off
a lot of songs that didn't match this
new vibe that i was in um especially
after writing about damn time or a boot
damn time as you guys would say
i wrote this like two months ago and i
think i had an epiphany that like oh
i only want songs that are
love
frequency like vary about love and also
bankers i want to make liz lizzo bangers
again so
um even if it's a ballad it bangs and i
think like
every song is memorable and delicious
and you want to hear it again and again
and again yeah i love that you're you're
playing or pulling double duty on
saturday night live as the host
and the musical guest what does that
feel like for you are you how excited
what are you more excited about
performing or hosting
well
i've already performed yes
but when i did perform
i didn't really talk about this but i
was so
sick i was so sick that i didn't even
really
enjoy
the performance yeah i could barely sing
the good as hell note though
because i was on an inhaler and i was on
all this stuff so like i actually am
really excited about performing again
because
now i feel like i get to perform my new
music which i'm super excited about but
now i'm gonna really get to be in it and
and show the world what i got because
that was me sick that was me
and on an inhaler so now you get to see
me really bringing it oh my gosh i'm so
excited well you're such a pro you're so
speaking of being a pro when acting
because
are you a person who you think will
break or will you be able to not laugh
in these skits like how hard is that
going to be for you
i'm that's the thing i'm actually most
nervous about because i've never done a
um like a like a live
interview on a late night show until i
did james corden right
in america which was great by the way it
was so good i was so nervous because i
was like oh my gosh i've never done this
before with like and what am i and i
kept laughing like i laughed so much
during our like our sing-off that we did
yeah and i was like y'all when i get to
snl i'm not gonna be able to stay in
character i'm so nervous about that
because i do i'm a smiley girl i smile a
lot but don't be nervous about that
because i think that just your joy's
going to shine through and we're going
to see that and it's going to make it
even better you're going to be you're
going to kill it it's going to be
awesome for sure
now what about um the iconic sasha flute
will she be making an appearance during
snl and r does she have a whole lot of
her own demands like her own rider or
what's going on oh my god you've been
talking to her people huh so you know
she's maybe so
disgustingly expensive
um her day rate
through the roof
um her yeah her writer her glam writer
diva under control diva with a capital d
uh right okay even though she's a c
flute by the way this for the music as
they know but she's a capital b
b i i feel sasha does make an appearance
um
in other places sasha is on about damn
time um there's a breakdown
that's sasha the flute so um you'll see
her there and you know we'll see if she
shows up to snl because she don't be
showing up these days she'll be on the
call you give it a call time she's like
i'll be there she don't show up she'll
be hours late you know what i'm saying
she might show up right afterwards for
the wrap party who knows i love that
okay last question because i know you
have to go snl is notorious for making
love matches scarlett and colin
kim and pete i have to ask you is a
sense of humor something you look for in
a partner
i love love
a funny man i actually
love comedians i have
i have a crush on i have a crush on a
comedian who i won't tell anyone just
it's i'm not going to tell you i can't
find you it's come on i can't tell you
do you want to know
oh
does he know does he know that you have
a crush he knows now
okay just you want to say
here
no
i tried i so tried for everyone that i
was trying to make a love match
okay
okay make it happen don't worry i'm
gonna make it happen you manifest that i
think he likes me too
how can he not i mean come on listen
congratulations for everything so
excited for all three it's it's so
wonderful and thanks for taking the time
today
thank you so much